is jordan mcpherson there with us todd
he is yeah he covers the marlins for the
miami herald and
jordan are you still with the team in
philadelphia i'm still in philadelphia
i'm not directly
in i'm not directing the same hotel or
anything or in the same vicinity as this
team but i am in philadelphia right now
why did the marlins play yesterday their
what they told us after the game sunday
is
they didn't think that the pickup as
they described it because they weren't
going to go in details about anything
copy related were
any bigger of a at least with only four
people
testing positive as we now know they
didn't think it was a big enough risk
to basically cancel the game they had
they so basically all the players
self-isolated at the hotel as soon as
they
got where the positive test and the team
thought that that would be enough
to keep the game going but when you look
at the grand scheme of things
all those players are the exception of a
player who tested brought because
positive at the beginning of the script
they all played the first two games so
everybody was
in some way shape or form potentially
exposed even if there wasn't a positive
test so it's
overall to me it was a big is a big head
scratcher but their exact response was
we take risks every day just by flying
just by traveling just by taking buses
and staying at hotels
so we know the risks are in play but if
we're told we're able to play we're
going to fly
but jordan does do the marlins make this
call or does major league baseball make
this call
to be able to play yesterday
i never got an exact answer that my
assumption would be that major league
baseball would be the ultimate
decider but nobody told them one way or
the other that they
that they had just they had to not play
so with
without being told one way or the other
whether or not they should play they
decided to go ahead and play
and now you have the the team is still
in philadelphia
like when when is everybody going home
that's the question they were originally
supposed to fly out about seven o'clock
last night
they moved that flight to originally
scheduled for about 11 15 this morning
because obviously after after getting
the news of the positive test yesterday
morning they did
they had everybody take some take a
quick rapid test which normally takes
about 24 hours
to get results but as of about 9 a.m
this morning their
flight that was supposed to leave for
miami at 11 o'clock was cancelled and
there is no update on that right now
so as we're right now they're in
philadelphia for honestly we don't know
how long it could be today they might
not
they might not leave they we honestly we
don't know right now but i'm also
wondering jordan at one point this is a
postponement
well at what point does this become a
forfeit for the marlins
that's a very good question and i mean
that type of decision is gonna have to
come down soon because
i mean in addition to the marlins just
think about what's going on with the
wrestling they
the new york ganky supposed to come into
philly and using the same club the very
same clubhouse and martin's to be used
for three days
there's supposed there's going to be
other parameters that go around the
league so this might
be more than just a single team
that gets impacted by this are you able
to do anything today in philadelphia are
you allowed to go anywhere have you been
tested
i have not personally been tested since
i've been up here but i've also
have not had direct contact i've
basically just been staying in my hotel
for the time being
that's probably smart yeah but i don't
know what did the braves and phillies
do since they played the marlins and now
everybody's got to get tested as you
mentioned the yankees now going to
philadelphia they're going to use that
same locker room
yeah it's gonna be there's a chance for
a serious domino
effect here if nlb doesn't
come up come out with whatever their
contingency plan is hopefully there is
one they
they haven't had to deal with the
situation yet but figuring out and
seeing what mlb does
in terms of responding to this over the
course of today is going to be
very very interesting how not only today
in this week plays out potentially the
rest of the season
it's unbelievable jordan good luck and
we appreciate you joining us on short
notice thank you
thank you that's jordan mcpherson he
covers the marlins for the miami hero